سيدي الرئيس، أنت تعلم أنك قلت مؤخرًا
إنك تعاملت وسأقتبس لك
الطريقة التي نقلت بها مع
بوتين المختلف، إنها مجموعة مختلفة تمامًا
من السمات في فترات مختلفة الآن
بالطبع واجه تمردًا
ومحاولة انقلاب من يفغيني باغوسيان  لقد
رأيت أي تغييرات
في الطريقة التي تعتقد أنه يتصرف بها في
سلوكه منذ محاولة الانقلاب
نعم نرى رد الفعل بعد
خطوات معينة من فاغنر نرى رد فعل بوتين
إنه ضعيف أولاً نرى أنه لا
يتحكم في كل شيء
يتحرك فاغنر في عمق روسيا
ويتأكد  تُظهر المناطق مدى سهولة
القيام بذلك.
بوتين لا يسيطر على الوضع في
المناطق ولا يتحكم في
الوضع الأمني. كلنا ندرك
أن جيشه بأكمله موجود في أوكرانيا،
والجيش بأكمله تقريبًا موجود هناك،
ولهذا السبب يكون الأمر سهلاً للغاية بالنسبة لفاغنر.
نحن ندرك أن بوتين لا يسيطر على
السياسة الإقليمية ولا
يسيطر على كل هؤلاء الأشخاص في المناطق،
لذا فإن كل رأس السلطة الذي كان يستخدمه قد
انهار للتو، هل
تصدق ذلك؟  إنه المسؤول الكامل عن
الجيش الآن عندما يتعلق الأمر
بخط المواجهة وهذا الهجوم المضاد،
هل تعتقد أن بوتين هو المسؤول بالكامل
عن الجيش الروسي؟
لا أعتقد أنه يتحكم بشكل كامل في جميع
العمليات التي يعطيها الأوامر
للقادة  من المفهوم أنهم
خائفون من فقدان وظائفهم لكنه لا
يفهم ولا يسيطر على
الطبقة الوسطى من الجيش الروسي ولا
الضباط والجنود ذوي الرتب الأدنى